but first we turn our attention to the
southern border
where the growing migrant crisis
continues to spiral out of control
we have brand new numbers from border
patrol tonight 171 000 migrants were
apprehended at the border
in the month of march that's up 60
percent
from february and it's the highest
monthly total in 15 years
even more disturbing the record number
of unaccompanied minors who crossed our
border last month
18 thousand five hundred children that's
seven thousand more than the previous
record for may
in 2019 now we saw how two of those
unaccompanied minors crossed the border
last night
two little girls sisters aged three and
five years old
tossed over a wall left to fend for
themselves
in the middle of a desert miles from
civilization
thankfully the girls are okay here they
are pictured with the hero border agents
who rescued them
el paso sector chief gloria chavez says
she was
horrified by what the coyotes did and
she is looking to hold them accountable
i kneeled down and just wondered as they
were talking to me
what kind of experiences or nightmares
they went through
from ecuador all the way to our border
that we don't even know about
because they were the ones that were
being carried by these ruthless
smugglers
with inhumane treatment of the most
vulnerable population in the world
children those girls are lucky to be
alive
and in this country in one piece others
are not so lucky far too many children
are abused sexually assaulted or
trafficked on their treacherous journeys
through central america
to our border a doctors without border
survey actually found that
31 percent of women and girls and 17
percent of boys
were sexually assaulted on their trips
to america
so familiar are migrant parents with the
assaults on children
that girls are loaded up with birth
control before they embark on their trip
to the cartels these kids are a
commodity no different than the illegal
guns or the drugs they bring into our
country
and for human smugglers business thanks
to joe biden
is booming every day they're making
upwards of
14 million dollars trafficking people
across the border the children who are
stolen into human sex trafficking rings
face a horrifying future from which they
will never
mentally or emotionally recover other
children
don't make it to this country at all
like the nine-year-old girl who drowned
in the rio grande
despite these daily horrors vice
president harris the person who said
we need to get these babies out of cages
and the person tasked
to fix our border crisis has no plans to
visit the border
or hold a formal news conference more
importantly
the biden administration has shown no
indication
that they plan to change their policies
to protect children
who are being used and abused by human
and sex traffickers
until they do this tragedy on the border
will continue